No,
no,
no.
The infinity war begins hello world it Saroj and a robotics company called
Boston dynamics released yet another incredible video demonstrating its flagship
robot,
the Atlas Doing Par Corp,
and I'm going to explain the technical details of how it works in this video.
This thing can now literally jump upstairs like a human.
In addition to being able to run in the forest without any tethers and perform a
bunch of acrobatic balancing acts,
this is so dope.
We can use humanoid robots like atlas to perform rescue operations in scenarios
that would otherwise be deadly for humans like firefighting or bomb disposal.
They can perform entertaining live shows involving wild stunts and maybe even
someday act as a personal companion performing chores for us humans and helping
us out in various ways.
If we read through the comments section though of these videos,
every other comment is something about terminator robots or some kind of
military usage.
Yes,
Darpa did fund the development of this robot,
but for performing search and rescue missions not combat and the United Nations
has already begun important and promising discussions on what a proper set of
regulations look like that prevents these robots from being used for homicide.
Boston dynamics began as a spinoff from MIT in [inaudible] 92 and thinks of its
robot,
the software and the physical world as one holistic pipeline.
Physical forces like the kinetic energy of motion and the force of gravity from
the world because the springs and gears of the robot to react in certain ways
and the robot response to this,
they also have this rapid experimentation mentality that I love,
build it,
break it,
fix it,
which is why we see them kicking their robots a lot.
So let's start off with the hardware of the latest version of atlas.
It's 1.5 meters tall and weighs 80 kilograms.
It has 28 degrees of freedom throughout its body.
Each degree of freedom is a different kind of motion the robot can make along an
axis,
say it's elbow or knee.
Think of them like the robotic analog,
two joints to power all of these joints.
The atlas robot uses a hydraulic power unit with high pressure oil.
Hydraulic systems convert mechanical energy into hydraulic energy.
When a hydraulic pump operates,
it performs two functions.
First,
it's mechanical action,
creates a vacuum at the inlet of the pump,
which allows atmospheric pressure to force liquid from the reservoir into the
inlet of the pump.
Next,
it's mechanical action delivers this liquid to the pump outlet and forces it
into the hydraulic system.
Besides robotics,
they're also using a wide range of applications from factory machinery to giant
Japanese mech robots.
Basically,
anytime an application requires heavy and systematic lifting or repeated use of
powerful and directional force,
bds hydraulic system can run for about half an hour up to a full hour without
needing to be tethered to a power source.
It consists mainly of a motor,
a reservoir,
and a hydraulic pump.
The system can generate a tremendous amount of power and is based on Pascal's
law of physics,
drawing its power from ratios of area and pressure.
The major difference between atlas and the vast majority of other humanoid
robots is that it's not powered by electric motors,
but by these hydraulic actuators driven by a battery powered electric pump.
Even though hydraulic actuation is more complex to set up,
it gives them way more power than electric motors and more compliance to absorb
shocks,
which is crucial to perform highly dynamic motions.
Atlas also uses a lidar to create a three map of its environment.
This is an imaging system that makes sense of an environment by bouncing lasers
off of it.
Then analyzing how they reflect back.
It's a precise range finder that operates in three d space.
Additionally,
it uses some stereo proximity cameras for situational awareness,
each pointed in different directions,
so don't try to surprise it.
All of these components are controlled by its onboard realtime control computer
and cooled by the onboard thermal management system.
One more thing to note here is that a lot of the parts were three d printed
because it's fast and efficient.
Darpa funded a robotics challenge for a couple of years and the atlas robot was
given to test to different academic teams.
The goal was to get a robot to perform eight tasks in different tracks,
including driving a vehicle and climbing a ladder.
It was a very difficult challenge and resulted in a lot of hilarious robot fail
videos for us to watch on youtube that dozens of teams that all had atlas robots
could spend as much time as they want it,
taking them apart and reverse engineering the hardware.
Despite this freedom,
none of them achieved performance anywhere near what Boston dynamics was doing
even before the challenge started.
Do you know what that means?
No.
It means the value of Boston dynamics is almost entirely in their closed source
control software.
What sort of algorithm could they possibly be using that's giving them such
amazing results?
The first thing that comes to mind is deep reinforcement learning.
In fact,
both Google and open AI have used deep RL to enable robots to manipulate
physical objects with unprecedented dexterity.
Luckily for us,
BDC CEO recently had a Q and a session at MIT where he was asked this question.
Let's hear what he had to say.
I'm sure we will use learning before too long.
Uh,
I'm not sure whether it will be deep reinforcement learning or something else,
but mostly we're interested in optimizing the complicated a stage space
partitioning.
We do know deep RL so far.
In fact,
they're not using any machine learning technology on that robot.
Incredibly.
You heard the man,
so what are they using?
They're likely using a sack of very carefully hand designed classic control
laws.
Classical control theory provides us with strong mathematical guarantees of
stability and performance without requiring alerting process.
It works out of the box if we've designed our control system properly,
but the scope of its abilities are limited.
Control Algorithms have to be designed specifically to perform a range of tasks.
If we change the task,
we need to redesign the control laws.
We can see on the web that Boston Dynamics developed a simulated atlas software
package for the Popular Gazebo robotics simulation environment.
This acts as a high level controller that lets developers make a set of joints
follow a desire trajectory specified as joint angles and it's a part of Ros,
the robot operating system,
which Alice has physical version probably uses as well.
Ross is a collection of software libraries aimed at simplifying the task of
creating robot behavior.
It allows us to create a control system where individual robotic components are
defined as nodes and can communicate data between each other at the protocol
level.
Framing our system this way is also beneficial for enabling concurrent movement
across the distributed set of components on the robot like moving an arm while
moving a leg.
If we know what the hardware components are and we can use Ross to create a
control system that encapsulates each component.
Then comes the question of the control algorithm to use on the system.
Like the CEO said an end to end approach is not used,
but instead several control algorithms each suited for different tasks probably
are the one they're using for walking looks pretty sick and a similar humanoid
robot.
Honda's Acimo a delightful human size lego piece.
Open source.
It's walking algorithm called zero moment point.
So let's start with that moment refers to a moment of inertia.
It's a tensor.
The amount of torque needed to cause any given angular acceleration is
proportional to the moment of inertia of a body.
Since robots have two points of contact with the floor,
their feet and they're supposed to walk,
run,
or jump.
Their motion needs to be planned in regard to the dynamical stability of their
whole body.
All the positions,
velocities,
and joint angles need to be taken into account.
This is nontrivial especially because the torso of the robot has a larger mass
and inertia than the legs which are supposed to support and move the robot.
It's like the problem of balancing an inverted pendulum.
It's heavier up top.
Then below,
the trajectory of a walking robot is planned using the angular momentum equation
to ensure that the generated joint trajectories allow for dynamical postural
stability and this is quantified by the distance of the zero moment point in the
boundaries of a predefined stability region.
The position of the ZMP is effected by the referred mass and inertia.
The robots torso,
since its motions generally require a large ankle torques to maintain stability,
ZMP accounts for the inertia of the robot and can tell when it's about to fall.
It's dynamically stable.
If we paused it in the middle of a step,
it could fall.
It works by calculating the zero point moment,
which is the spot at which all your inertia is canceled out by the angle at
which you catch yourself.
It's like sticking your foot out to catch a fall.
That's what the robot is doing.
ZMP is still inefficient.
It requires a very large ankle torques because it's in a near constant state of
fall.
If we walk slowly with a 20 degree bend at our knees,
keeping our feet as flat as possible,
we can simulate what it's like.
Basically the ankles are responsible for pushing the robot up,
but two,
they probably aren't using ZMP at least anymore.
They've got to be using a combination of more dynamical control strategies.
There's actually been a lot of work in this space capture point,
control model,
predictive control,
quadratic programming,
direct inverse,
dynamical optimization.
All of these strategies are worthy of a full course in robotics.
It's too much to fit into one video and that's not even including any machine
learning,
which is exciting.
There are three things to remember.
Austin dynamics is powered using a very efficient hydraulic power unit which
Converts Mechanical Energy into hydraulic energy.
The zero moment point algorithm is used to help bipedal robots walk,
run,
and jump by computing a stabilized trajectory for the robot and Boston dynamics
likely uses a stack of different dynamical control algorithms to help it's robot
perform motion.
What was your first reaction when you saw Apolis to par core?
Let me know in the comments section and hit subscribe if you want to see more
educational videos.
For now,
I've got to run to really sell.
Thanks for watching.